hello and welcome to this video how is
it possible that i have black against ha
gay like in ninety percent of the games
please tell me how it is possible i
always have black against them it's
really amazing ok Knight f3 okay well if
or if always right but still let's play
it Knight to e5 uh-huh Joe push up to
six maybe or taking both probably okay
okay let's just develop
yeah long class altar is kind of kind of
interesting here well let's cancel I'm
not sure if he's happy with short
castles now an aged five is immediately
putting out some threads yeah so he's
going for going long maybe yeah we
should be three
let's play this now open open the
position what to do we should be for 495
I can also also centralized it's
probably probably roughly equal you be
surprised if anybody could have
something here my pieces are very active
and harmonious and he's got the two-cent
the pawns which shouldn't be a super
important yeah I threatened to t a play
94 so he's going away yeah 95 I don't
know doesn't doesn't really net much at
the end maybe just age five
that's interesting okay
mmm yeah that I didn't didn't really
evaluate correctly especially f4f whoa
that looks pretty good for white not
sure how bad it is but it wasn't that
wasn't what I wanted ok at least I want
to jump prevent any quick further
expansion there ok here yeah Bishop age
five maybe the bishop on age seven looks
totally ridiculous so let's put him
92 g streams not so bad it's got a
really high rating for his standard
sudanese floating in the lower 2200 i
could have checked actually and maybe
take stuff yeah I'm come on keep
checking him I don't see what he has or
is it wrapping my queen or anything I
don't believe it let's see h3 is also
attacked
OOP gee wonder i take that inch bone
okay wait I can take on f4 here right
anything better know I can take the
other queen is protected grab this one
well that looks okay two points them
even though they might be attacked
quickly
that's not so easy and now I can take it
III not true
that looks pretty good job threatening
rookie to as well it looks at least look
somewhat threatening I know fear roped
into I don't see what is playing out of
that Quincy for what is the point I can
take here and play Queen edge to check
this is a text maybe this is the thing I
can also check here on edge one after
which Bishop see one has to be played
Roxy three chick Roxy three are not
check with attacking taking a queen I
don't see you in there shame
it should be good though I mean where's
he going I've Queen d3 checking now I've
got crazy static this is an easy win
Quincy for was the only move after which
I jig and 37 age too yeah okay now us
interesting interesting position yeah
well I probably has some what u equal
ish or something in the round here but
maybe even I have to improve somewhere
here there's this location before and an
f4 looked a kind of annoying making the
engine still is either says it's okay
it's equal ish f5 ok I can actually take
a five thats it's bad could have taken
her because he now is this the good
development this is helping ok i went to
age 5 g 6 taking this Queen g5 was just
move it snatch the poor now yeah just
taking things and now we have this
position yeah Brooke Brooke g one g 5 is
also interesting instead a mistake no
it's also winning for black takes and
looked into wins actually I cannot tell
you why here I look give 1s winning here
why I hope the one Bishop see one Bishop
e3 is actually quite good check HERE
chance Queen age too because there is a
major ok I didn't see that one I only
saw this continuation check which
however also wins it ok and so so this
idea i'll just take care that's also
pretty strong and now the age porn is
just doing a good job this is also
hanging I just have to check that
good backrack made as a thing so when
when he played this it was already lost
I wasn't totally sure that I'm can come
gently winning here with an H pond today
I didn't see the h1 I just said okay I'm
to one's up and it should be good but
the age bonus is very very quick yeah
it's isn't that funny i have got black
against this guy's so often it's really
really funny okay well thanks for
watching